hi there this is Steve here again I just
want to follow up on my last video where
I said that language learning is a is a
subconscious process and you know if
that is the case then we have to let the
language come to us and I think far too
often and language learning either the
teacher wants to force us to learn
something or we try to force ourselves
to learn something and of course it
doesn't happen that way and I want to
use a couple of recent examples I had my
discussion this morning with my one of
my Romanian tutors and of course I look
forward to these discussions because I
spent so much time listening and reading
that when I get a live native speaker I
want to speak I want to try to use what
I've learned and with my two other
tutors we have very pleasant discussions
but with this fellow I have to keep on
trying to keep them on track to do it my
way
so we start speaking and I say three
words no stop and in English no this is
not correct you must do this that and I
say never mind I just want to talk now
the system at Lync is that you can write
all my mistakes phrases in a report
which you'll send to me and I will study
them but we just want to talk okay so we
continue talking one more sentence he
stops me again it's pronounced wrong
it's this is wrong it should be that
each other this one like three or four
times and finally I got mad I said you
know is it so difficult for you to
understand I don't want you to correct
me I won't remember your Corrections and
all it does is make me lose interest in
the conversation I forget what I was
trying to say we were talking about
actually we were had a very interesting
discussion we eventually ended up having
a really interesting discussion about
the communist regime that came into
Romania after the Second World War and
the events that led up to that and what
happened in between the wars and the
various right-wing factions in Romania
and Yalta and
the West basically betrayed Eastern
Europe and we had a fascinating
discussion and I'm I know I made lots of
mistakes but I wanted to speak Romanian
oh this is part of my gradual exposure
he cannot force me to speak correctly
and all of his corrections are not going
to make me speak correctly they're just
gonna diminish my enjoyment in speaking
and they're gonna make me speak less and
they're gonna make me more inhibited why
is he trying to force me to speak
correctly before I am able to speak
correctly as I say language learning is
a subconscious process I will speak
incorrectly for a long long time and
gradually I will learn to speak more
correctly because I will notice myself a
lot of the mistakes that I make and of
course if I get his reports I'll see you
there some of the mistakes that I made
and often were conscious when we're
speaking of the things that we kind of
have trouble saying or that we're not
sure about is this right or wrong and I
think the real advantage of speaking is
that we become more aware of these areas
that you want to focus in on so that the
next time we read or listen to something
we're kind of again trying to be
attentive at least I am zooming in on
these areas with the knowledge that with
more and more exposure gradually these
things become more natural to me and
I've noticed just in the two weeks that
I've been speaking and of course
continuing my by listening and reading
I'm just able to say so much more now
and I'm able to understand so much more
so I'm conscious of the progress that I
am making but it is very much
a subconscious process so that was one
thing
another exists so there's an example of
where the teacher is trying to force you
to be better than you can be you're not
gonna be that good you're gonna make
mistakes eventually you'll get better in
my belief another person said to me you
know how do you learn idioms in a
language and I know that that a lot of
people are very intent on learning
idioms and slang so I thought about this
and I said you know what actually I paid
no attention to it
when I'm learning a language because
when I start into a language everything
is new to me the words are new the
pronunciation is new the word order the
way they say things like in Romanian
they have some of the strangest ways of
expressing the future what
quite unlike I shouldn't say strange I
you know objectively strange strange to
me quite unlike other Romance languages
so all of these things I have to get
used to it's a great big jigsaw puzzle
with only a few pieces there in the case
of Romanian more pieces than I had in
Russian or Czech because I bring with me
all the vocabulary that I have from
other Romance languages but still there
are a lot of new pieces in this new
language that I have to get used to so
every soft my screen goes blank and I
don't know what's going on anyway so
idioms so I say to myself you know I
don't worry about idioms because there's
so many other things that I have to
learn first the idioms are there you
know if there's an idiom that the Google
Translate doesn't translate for me and
I'm left with these three or four words
in a phrase that doesn't make any sense
to me I would just leave it that's not
the only thing I don't understand in the
language all of these things will
gradually subconsciously start to become
clear as I said in one of my other
videos the fog will slowly lift but you
can't force it so now if you absolutely
want to learn idioms or slang you know
fine but I don't see any necessity to do
that and I don't think it creates a very
good impression with a native speaker
because it's almost it's not expected
that the non-native speaker used these
idioms and slang and if I think you can
only use those when you are actually
very advanced in the language and where
you actually use it naturally because
again these idioms and slang or whatever
have been absorbed in some kind of a
subconscious process through lots of
reading and listening and so then you
start to use it naturally but if you try
to use it
almost artificially because you studied
it from a list of you know idiomatic
expressions it actually sounds strange
it's presumptuous because it implies a
degree of familiarity with the language
and the culture which in fact you don't
have so here again I think people who
are intent on learning idioms it's
another example of people trying to rush
things
let the language come to you the moment
will come in your studies where you will
naturally start to use idioms and much
earlier than that you'll start to
understand them now you can of course
look at a list of idioms just as I I
don't but if you're terribly interested
look at them but don't be disappointed
if you don't remember them
I look at grammar rules from time to
time I think vaguely helps me notice
things in the language but it's it seems
amazing how quickly I forget the grammar
rules that I looked at but I kind of
think it helps me be you know more
attentive so we can do that but not with
the idea of trying to learn it not with
the idea of trying to force yourself to
remember it because that all those
conscious efforts a conscious effort of
the teacher to get you to say it
correctly a conscious effort to read the
grammar rule or to study the list of
idioms all those deliberate efforts to
master the language the basic building
blocks and all of that stuff is largely
a futile effort gradually through enough
exposure through enough reading
listening using the language interacting
with people subconsciously the language
things will start to click in for you as
long as you remain motivated determined
and spend enough time with the language
so the message here is almost like a
corollary of the idea that languages are
learned basically subconsciously and
that is that we should not push things
teachers shouldn't push things at
students students shouldn't put pressure
on themselves but rather just let the
language come to you and some things
will come earlier
and fun some things will come later and
there you have it so sit back and enjoy
the journey the journey to fluency